aujourd'hui je vais m'opposer totalement
au revenu universel traditionnel mais je
vais plaider pour un revenu universel
augmentée qui se base sur la donner
commençons d'abord par une petite
définition alors le revenu universel
augmentée sera déployée sous la forme
d'un service de haute qualité à partir
des données que vous livrer aux
entreprises ou via une redistribution
d'un montant va leur donner que vous
pouvez convertir dans la monnaie de
votre choix ou dans la crypte aux
monnaies de votre choix
cette liberté marge de manoeuvre est
fondamental aujourd'hui pour avoir une
richesse beaucoup plus importante
ce qui est intéressant c'est que là le
revenu universel traditionnels
aujourd'hui constitue un obstacle c'est
qu'il se base sur une fondation
monétaire et nous savons aujourd'hui que
la redistribution se base sur une
croissance monétaire et nous savons que
la monnaie aujourd'hui est extrêmement
fragile et ne peut nous garantir une
survie sociale dans les années à venir
après cette introduction nous allons
nous poser la question pourquoi un
revenu universel augmenté alors les deux
premiers éléments de réponse c'est que
effectivement il faut refondre le pacte
social qui n'a pas été constitué depuis
tant et tant d'années depuis tant et
tant de débats et de l'autre côté
pouvoir aboutir à cette société du bien
être est ce qui est intéressant à que le
revenu universel augmenté c'est qu'il se
base sur une donnée et contrairement à
la monnaie la donne et se compose de
cinq aspects fondamentaux
le premier aspect c'est que la donne et
nous la produisons tous et toutes de
manière individuelle libre sans risque
sans interruption effectivement sans
effort donc ces cinq aspects
fondamentaux nous permettent de repenser
un avenir beaucoup plus radieux avec un
revenu universel améliorer le deuxième
aspect c'est que la donnée à deux vertus
contrairement à la monnaie la première
vertu c'est que la donnée est
indivisible c'est à dire que avec une
quantité de données nous pouvons
pertinemment investir dans une
entreprise à une entreprise b en même
temps son diminuer la valeur ou le
volume de ces données deuxième élément
c'est qu'elle est infinie depuis tant et
tant d'années nous
on laissait les débats fiscaux nous
tourmenter économiquement pour repenser
la redistribution
alors que nous avons à disposition une
donnée qui est infinie essais débats
incessants sont illustrés par robert
nozick et john rawls alors robert nozick
fustigé le fait que john roll souhaitait
prendre une partie de la richesse des
plus aisées pour la redistribuer aux
moins nantis ils y voyaient une forme
d'intervention arbitraire alors ici avec
la donne et nous sommes capables de
réconcilier la pensée égalitariste et
libertarienne ou tout simplement
réconcilier la gauche et la droite
la deuxième raison qui doit nous pousser
à adopter le revenu universel augmenté
concerne la valeur de la donner nous
savons pertinemment aujourd'hui que la
valeur de la donnée est supérieur à la
valeur de la monnaie et donc pourquoi
continuer sur cette base monétaire
il n'y a aucune garantie surtout que
depuis 2008 il eu une crise financière
et donc nous avons mis en place des
politiques monétaires pouvoir relancer
l'économie baisse des taux d'intérêt
pour vous octroyer un prêt plus
facilement ou encore la planche à
billets donc le fait d'imprimer de la
monnaie
sauf que ces deux mécanismes ont
tendance à faire baisser la valeur de
l'argent circulation ou de l'argent que
vous avez dans votre poche
pourtant nous avons des données à
disposition qui connaissent un destin
opposé
ce qui est intéressant avec les données
ce que nous en produisons tous les jours
et que le volume croissant ne fait pas
baisser la valeur de la donner chaque
jour nous produisons plus de 10
milliards de dollars de données et 50%
de cette de ce montant extraordinaire et
jeté à la poubelle
donc il y a une capacité de production
qu'on pourrait retirer tribu et à la
société sous forme de revenu universel
augmentée qui disparaît nous amène vers
le prochain point le fait que nous
soyons condamnés à être riches alors la
donne et contrairement à la monnaie est
une garantie
je vous prends un exemple lorsque vous
allez à la banque et que vous octroyer
un prêt il y à un taux d'intérêt ce taux
d'intérêt correspond à votre probabilité
ou votre solvabilité
le fait que vous soyez capable dans le
futur dors en bourse
cette dette au présent mais il ya une
contrainte à cela c'est à dire que vous
devez absolument promettre plusieurs
unités de travail dans le futur pour un
besoin présent donc c'est une manière de
confisquer votre futur pour un besoins
présents et en réalité même si nous
mettions en place un revenu universel
traditionnels nous ne pouvons absolument
pas garantir votre votre survie
économique tout simplement parce que le
revenu universel traditionnel
n'intègrent pas les risques aléatoires
de crise financière future ou encore les
problématiques que vous pouvez connaître
dans votre parcours professionnel
c'est pour cela que la donnée est
beaucoup plus intéressante à ce sujet
parce qu'elle est créée sans
interruption et cette liberté de pouvoir
créer de la donne et nous permet de
penser que notre richesse n'est pas
indexé au travail mais il est indexé au
simple fait de vivre et c'est un
fondement extraordinairement positif qui
nous permettent et qui doit nous faire
penser à un revenu universel augmenter
le fait que la donnée ne soit pas indexé
au travail mais plutôt simple fait de
vivre nous mène vers le prochain point
le fait que nous soyons condamnés à être
libre ce qui est intéressant avec elle à
donner c'est qu'elle fonde sa légitimité
sur le simple fait de vivre et nous
avons une capacité naturelle et surtout
libre de créer de la donner et donc de
créer une valeur ajoutée
cela nous mène vers un nouveau monde une
nouvelle société où tout est
décentralisée c'est une manière beaucoup
plus intéressant de voir une démocratie
qui ne sera pas totalement effritée
si effectivement nous mettons en place
ce type de revenu universel augmenter
cette liberté de pouvoir créer de la
donner et donc de battre valeur ou de
battre monnaie nous permet en réalité
d'accéder au bonheur
si nous prenons
la conception spinoziste du grand
philosophe spinoza
il est en effet certain que pour aboutir
à une société du bien-être et donc au
bonheur la liberté et sinequanon et
heureusement nous disposons aujourd'hui
de données qui nous aide à le faire
chaque jour et c'est très important de
pouvoir le considérer contrairement à la
monnaie aujourd'hui qui est centralisé
qui a une valeur inférieure qui nous
divise et finalement qui nous permet pas
de repenser le pacte social dont nous
avons toutes ces housses besoin mais
avant d'aboutir à cette société libre et
donc aboutir à une société du bien-être
ou du bonheur il faut absolument penser
à protéger ou à encadrer ce revenu
universel augmenter et donc la question
c'est comment mettre en place un revenu
universel augmenté la première chose
c'est que il faut s'assurer d'avoir une
double redistribution la première peut
se faire via des offres de meilleure
qualité grâce aux données que nous
investissons dans toutes les entreprises
donc ça permet également de les aider
pour améliorer leur valeur ajoutée mais
aussi nous nous permettre d'avoir un
service de meilleure qualité et
peut-être même moins cher et le deuxième
élément pouvoir assurer une
redistribution d'un montant va leur
donner que nous pouvons convertir dans
n'importe quelle monnaie ou dans
n'importe quelle cryptome n'est ce point
ci est fondamental c'est ce qui donne
vie au revenu universel par la donnée ou
revenu universel augmenté mais
effectivement la question qu'on pourrait
se poser c'est comment donner une valeur
à ces données
c'est très simple il faut construire une
architecture une architecture qui permet
de donner une valeur à une donnée à ou
une donnée b le cas existe déjà pour pas
mal de secteurs notamment le secteur
financier
pour la petite histoire nous savons
pertinemment que il y à des produits
extrêmement complexe on finance pour
lesquelles on a des modèles
mathématiques extrêmement complexe avec
lesquels on a des prix
des prix des actions prix des
obligations ou autre alors partant de ce
postulat là il n'est pas impossible de
pouvoir construire une architecture pas
similaire mais avec la même abstraction
dans la modélisation pour créer une
valeur aux données que nous délivrons de
manière gratuite chaque jour et donc
ceci nous amène vers le dernier point du
comment la protection il est fondamental
de pouvoir créer un encadrement pour
pouvoir protéger chacune et chacun dans
cette disposition naturelle est libre de
produire de la richesse et donc de
produire de la valeur
il est inconcevable de pouvoir repenser
cette société de demain sur base du
revenu universel augmenter si nous nous
assurons pas d'avoir un encadrement
juridique
par conséquent il faut déployer des
forces juridique extraordinaire pour
repenser le modèle économique de demain
basé sur le revenu universel augmenté il
faut éviter que ces données que nous
produisons chaque jour soit utilisé à
mauvais escient ou soient volés par des
personnes tierces
alors j'appelle ici tous les juristes et
tous les avocats à pouvoir nous aider
nous assister pour pouvoir repenser le
modèle de demain
quelquefois la donne et peut nous
effrayer
mais contre intuitivement elle nous
offre des capacités extraordinaires pour
repenser le futur et la société de
demain
il faut s'extraire de ce paradigme
monétaire et embrassait le paradigme par
la donnée pour constituer un revenu
universel augmenter et pour garantir le
futur de chacun et de chacune
depuis tant d'années nous avons eu des
débats nous avons pas réussi à aboutir à
cette social pacs et ses idées il faut
s'en saisir et c'est évidemment toujours
les idées subversives et transgressive
qui nous aide à avancer un peu comme
l'idée de charles quint au 16ème siècle
d'importer la renaissance au sein d'ubs
au palais d'al kassara séville ou encore
françois 1er qui tue
de manière ingénieuse le talent de rosso
au sein du château de fontainebleau ou
encore averroès qui nous permet de
penser la société médiévale par la
raison ou enfin le grand philosophe
spinoza qui nous permet qui nous a
permis de comprendre nos rapports à la
liberté
alors je ne pouvais pas vous promettre
une société de bien-être pour demain
mais aujourd'hui nous avons les
ingrédients nous avons la possibilité de
pouvoir redistribuer la richesse de
manière beaucoup plus intelligente grâce
revenu universel augmenté